live chairman
thank you sonya
good evening everyone and welcome to
rochford district council's remote
meeting of the executive a warmer
welcome
to visiting members and also
a welcome to members of the public who
are
viewing this meeting via the youtube
live stream
everyone is here so uh where item one is
concerned
we no need to take any apologies because
everyone is here i believe
uh sonia and if turning to item
two on the agenda sonia you will be kind
enough to read out
the names of any non-members attending
thank you chairman we have councillor
julie gooding
councillor michael hoy councillor dave
sparing
councillor mike wilkinson councillor
laurene shaw
councillor bob milne and councillor
george yuano
thank you sonya
agenda item three minutes
i believe um before we move to
agreeing the minutes um council award
you made mention to me earlier that you
may have a question on the minutes
council thank you very much leader yes
um it's just uh in regards
to it actually reflects on item seven
which we will be coming to and it
is uh 3.4
on page 7.1
when i looked at that and i noticed it
said the program
update was presented to the executive on
3rd of february 2021.
uh just in the minutes it just says it
was
it was just a spoken
report as opposed to anything else
and i i feel that realistically because
we wish to be as
open as transparent uh as we as we
always say we want to be
i feel just having a transcript or even
a brief note
as to what was discussed uh and spoken
at that meeting i think would be very
very helpful
thank you thank you councillor thank you
council board
if i could refer to the acting managing
director
angela hatchings if you would like to
make comment
thank you chairman um just to say yes
i'm very happy to
insert additionality into the minutes
the minutes themselves do reflect a lot
of detail
with uh the full statement of the deputy
leader
the for just to refresh my members
memory
the update was essentially setting the
scene for the connect
transformation program uh explaining the
various work streams that would sit
beneath it introducing angela hogg
the project manager and reaffirming that
that
project would now be a gold project and
fall within the reporting
cycle of the pmo as you say
council award the reporter which is
later on the agenda
thank you very much members are there
any other
matters arising from the
right in that case can i take it
that the minutes are agreed please
members
agreed
right great
center thank you very much indeed okay
moving on to agenda item four to receive
decorations of
interest are there any decorations of
interest
i can't see anyone responding
but i would like to refer to
agenda item eight appendix one
uh table a makes reference
to grants that have been awarded in the
financial year
2020-21 and as a
committee member of memory lane
dementia cafe that is a
recipient of one of the grants i just
need to
declare the backbone
moving on to agenda item five questions
on notice from councillors
members have been no questions received
for this meeting
which takes us to item six matters
referred to the executive on reports
from other committees
there are none members agenda item seven
the council projects programmer
management office this
the acting managing director andrew
hutchings will introduce the report
please
angela thank you chairman members this
is the quarterly report of the projects
programme
office which reports on the council's
gold and silver projects
last month members had a verbal update
from the assistant director
transformation and customer
to lay the groundwork of the connect
program and um
from this quarter onwards the project
will report formally through the
pmo process the other two projects which
are the subject of this report are the
council's asset delivery program
and the beagle project members should
note that
uh e put the administrative
administrators of the national
vaccine center programme for our area
have now said that the freight house
will not be used as a vaccination center
so that is an update to the comments
within the report
but members if you have any questions
about the asset delivery program
the project senior responsible owner
matt hold white is here to assist
and with your permission chairman um i
know that councillor fd
as portfolio holder for tourism would
like to update members regarding the
beagle event
thank you angela thank you and over head
over to councillor
at that point thank you thank you
chairman uh i had a meeting to gather
some ideas of what to do with the
underspend
of the beagle event which was for 2020
and it looks like we'll be investing the
money in a
as you say now a real life event with
actual people
so we're going to be in touch with the
town and parish councils to
look at future calendar dates thank you
thank you councillor
i have a um question from
councillor rowe
thank you chairman um it's just
simulation um
angela to the de canton of number 19
which i believe we're on target for and
should be emptied by the first of april
is that correct
that's as i understand it councillor oh
yes absolutely thank you
and just my thanks to angela hogg um
and the team um for
you know the the connect program it's
moving moving on swiftly
i'm pleased to say and in conjunction
with the um
asset development programme so thank you
very much to everyone
thank you councillor any more questions
before i
ask one i can't see anyone signaling
um can i refer please to uh
3.6 please and
you know very proudly we say planning
has started the staff development
program which will equip staff with the
skills they need to operate
as 21st century public servants and
serve the council's residence in an
agile
and responsive way can i just ask
you please angela just to sort of set
out
your vision for what that actually what
that actually looks like because i
believe it's actually very exciting
and i'd just like to understand in uh
shall i say more layman speak
exactly how you envisage that
um yes absolutely the um the 21st
century public servant
is a government study um undertaken some
little while now which sets out the
characteristics
of forward thinking and proactive local
government in particular
and so what we are looking to do with
our staff is to work with them as part
of our evolution through digital
technology
to ensure that not only are they
operating processes which
uh aid and assist the efficient delivery
of their day-to-day services but also
that they
are able to use digital technology
um to create their own efficiencies and
to improve performance
so that they can be more proactive in in
dealing with the
requirements of both the democratic
processes
um as which we as a council have and
also our customer
needs thank you very much
angela and if i also refer to uh
3.12
which refers to the council offering the
freight house
there's a potential coding 19
vaccination center i would just like to
update members that obviously we're very
proud of the fact that the
mill hall is now being used as a
vaccination center it's been
i think we're on something like about
the ending of the third week
um but the freight house we understand
from the nhs
will not be required and that is really
because of the
tremendously successful rollout of the
program
and the numbers that have been
thankfully vaccinated
very much according and actually ahead
of schedule
and i just want to pay tribute to the
work of
everyone that has made that program so
successful in rockford
certainly doctor's surgeries both in
rayleigh
and in rockford are now supported by
pharmacies
and certainly when you look at other
vaccination centers
they are serving residents extremely
well so whilst i would have been very
happy
to offer the freight house and it still
isn't a lot but i think in terms of
capacity
uh the nhs collectively have done an
absolutely wonderful job
in meeting the demands or the rochford
residents so i'm very appreciative but i
thought that would just be helpful to
clarify that point
okay um so ah council about you wish to
come back
thank you chairman um just to concur
with what you've said
um i think it should be made well known
that
us as a district council put various um
of our sites forward to the nhs and it
was not the rochefort district council's
delay
in getting these um coming forward we
actually did offer them in good time
i think it's fair that everybody knows
that thank you yes
in in indeed council very important
point it was last december when we first
knew that
we would be offering sites but also i
would like to add
the incredible response from uh
businesses and offers from volunteers
within our community
to also support the program it really is
beyond belief the kindness of businesses
in the district that have offered
premises
um i please don't want them to be
offended that they haven't actually been
taken up because the rollout of the
program
uh has been uh demanding uh but
uh the fact that uh businesses
those very kind offers from other
community places have been made
is a real tribute to the community
spirit in this district but
uh please do not be offended uh the fact
that uh
it just wasn't possible to take up all
those that were
offered so uh so there we are
but moving back to the report before us
um members is one recommendation set out
on paragraph 1.1
page 7.1 of the report to note the
update
on the asset delivery program adp and
the
connect program is that noted members
no teacher thank you chairman
thank you very much moving on to
agenda item number eight the process for
awarding
voluntary sector grants 2021
2022 i hand over to
the portfolio holder for community
councillor mike
webb who will present the report
counselor
thank you chairman thank you for the
opportunity to present this report
chairman this this report is good news
for our district
i'm sure members have had a chance to
read through it
but i would just like to pick out some
key points
for members if that's okay the purpose
of the report is to continue to support
our voluntary sector within the district
to provide a voluntary sector grant
scheme for the year ahead
worth approximately ten thousand pounds
and also to continue to support rayleigh
and rochford district association of
voluntary services
through a top slice of the funding as
well
in the report in section three
there's an outline of what those the
criteria for those grants and how it
will work
and we're going to be opening up to the
community and any one group
can apply for up to a thousand maximum
of a thousand pounds of revenue funding
with no capital funding available and
we're going to be asking those groups
to allocate against
three criteria which will be reducing
overweight and obesity levels
improving mental health and well-being
and supporting people to lead
independent lives and to stay in their
own homes
and an additional funding will be
allocated subject to applicants
demonstrating
how their activities contribute to the
district's community resilience
this will be overseen by a member
advisory group
which i will be chairing
in addition in 3.4 it's outlined that
the funding to ramps will be top sliced
and will total 15k
german i'd like to draw attention of
members to 3.6 and the appendix if
that's okay
because it outlines how successful this
scheme was
last year not only were we able to
support
ravs to the tune of fifteen thousand
pounds but we also gave out a total of
eleven awards
um to our local voluntary sector ranging
from nine hundred pounds to per thousand
pounds
and chairman in appendix one i just like
to draw members attention to appendix
one
it actually outlines this work in our
district
the work of ravs recruiting 275
community based volunteers to support
the outcome
of the the hub it also lists the work
that was carried out
through essex community first aid events
volunteers
where they're able to not just purchase
a defibrillator but actually to carry
out the training for those who would be
using it
it was able to the funding was able to
support carers and families working
together
in contact with and supporting around
170 young people
and approximately 150 families from
across the district
in addition the memory lane cafe was
supported
um looking to able to access services
for those who required extra support
the essex axe-based service had
equipment in place
to support those in our community wyvern
community transport provided free food
parcel deliveries
for those in our community and then
finally chairman the mega center after i
turned you to
page 8.7 was able to work
with a community hub to provide a
telephone response helpline
benefiting the most vulnerable in our
community and that led to literally
thousands of people in our district
receiving not just
food parcels but able to access the
medication and their prescriptions
without this work our district would be
a much poorer place
and so chairman i'm pleased to say that
we are recommending that this grant
scheme continues for the year ahead
that rabs will receive 15 000 pounds top
slice
and the voluntary sector grant will be
ten thousand pounds again in the year
ahead
i don't think we should underestimate
this achievement chairman i know many
other local
council web you've just moved on to mute
council of web we missed the last part
of your your words because you've moved
on to mute for some reason you gentlemen
just to say we should recognize the work
in our district that we continue to
support our voluntary sector
and many other local authorities no
longer do this but within rochford we're
continuing to invest in the third sector
and we're continuing to ensure that our
voluntary organizations
are well supported and that they are
funded as well thank you
councillor thank you very much indeed
just before i pass it out for
questions i'm not sure whether assistant
director louisa moss wishes to add
anything
i know you're available to answer any
questions alongside councillor webb did
you wish to add anything
louisa no um no thank you leader i think
councillor webb summed up
the report um concisely i'm just here
for questions if needed
absolutely thank you very much indeed
councillor smith
thank you uh chairman um can i just
confirm
that what we're doing here is not a
statutory
function we're talking about voluntary
sector grants but this is a voluntary
operation of the uh district council and
it's something that we are
choosing to do rather than we need to do
it
thank you thank you councilman smith
councillor webb do you wish to answer
that yes thank you councillor smith yes
we
this is not a statutory obligation we
choose to do this we choose to support
our voluntary sector
and we choose to recognize the good
value in our community
and as i suggest look said in in the
appendix and the report
it outlines the work that is doing in
the community the additive value that
that is bringing to our residents
and i very much anticipate that in the
year ahead the community grant scheme
will continue to support a voluntary
sector
which in turn will continue to enable
those in our community to be well looked
after and well cared for thank you
councillor you have a question so
not so much as a question uh chairman
it's just uh
i was also involved in the early stages
of the
mega center in the hub as quite a few of
the other councillors
here as well even across party and
the work they did especially rabs and
the mega center
beginning of this covid19 when everybody
was moving
from real life into working remotely was
amazing
and i think they deserve everything
they've got and hopefully for many more
years into the future
thank you councillor i can't see any
more
hands i would just like to say how proud
i am to be
leader of an authority which sets aside
up to 25 000 pounds for as councillor
smith said
a totally non-statutory service the work
that we are doing
in the community is truly amazing
and i think it is a real tribute
to this authority that in these
cash-strapped times
we are able to set aside a significant
sum of money
within our budget to continue that good
work so
i pay tribute to you councillor webb
under your stewardship
and officers involved and other members
who will be involved
in the process for the excellent work
that
is going on here i can't see any more
questions or comments so in that case
i will turn to the recommendations and i
will read them out
at paragraph 1.1 to 1.3
there are three recommendations
1.1 to put in place a procedure for
allocating the voluntary sector grants
fund for the financial year 2021
to 2022 1.2
to agree that this process remains clear
and transparent
whilst aligning outcomes with those
identified
in the rockford district council
business plan
relating to partnership working and
links to the joint
rockford and castle point health and
well-being strategy
and 1.3 to agree that the raidy
rochard and district association for
voluntary services
will receive top-sized funding from the
same pot
based on outcomes aligned with the essex
county council
performance framework and the hwbs
action plan
members i will move the three
recommendations do i have a second
please
council of all chairmen uh right
okay i had a few hands go up there but
council award let me take your uh
second note please um now members
are you happy to vote on these three
recommendations together
i will assume you're in agreement unless
you click on your raised hand
icon wait a few moments
no i can't see anyone wishing to take
them
separately so moving on to the next
stage of the process
please unmute yourself and advise me if
you're not able to use the electronic
hand
and raise your hand manually so that it
can be counted
members if anyone would like a recorded
boat to be taken please click
on the raised hand icon once
so it looks to me as if everyone can
vote
and it looks to me as if we do not need
to take a recorded
vote
so in that case um
voting will be done by an electronic
show of hands
all those in favor of the
recommendations please click
on your raised hand icon once
thank you chairman
[Music]
german that's fine thank you i think
that's unanimous isn't it
it is unanimous thank you thank you very
much
you may lower your raised pen
thank you very much um
moving on to agenda item nine
which refers to the lease of the former
crown hill
public convenience the portfolio holder
for commercial
business local economy and leisure
councillor danielle belton
will introduce the report please
councillor belton
thank you chairman the report sets out
the proposal to
publicly market the leasehold
opportunity to the asset known as the
former crown hill toilets
as marked out in section three of the
report in line with the council's
disposal framework
the asset is deemed surplus to
requirement and as it doesn't meet at
least one objective in the asset
strategy
and therefore granting a lease would
also support a business
the business plan to maximize our assets
a professional valuation has been
undertaken and has given
a guide lease price of 12 000 pound per
annum
but given the current market we need to
note that this is an indication of
potential
valuation only the report was drafted
some year ago but given the pandemic it
was put on hold
however now that we can start to see an
end in sight it's vital
that the council lead by example and do
what they can to ensure prime units in
the town are occupied by a good mix of
diverse users
it's proposed that the space be marketed
through expressions of interest being
sought
including fit out plans and intention of
use
this will allow consideration of the
business plans
and the viability of all proposals
railey high street is a key part of our
district and it's important for
residents and businesses alike that
units be filled
and so as we start to register towards
some normality our high streets can all
start to thrive again
thank you also belton thank you very
much indeed
i know that um assistant director matt
harwood white
is also there to support you in
answering any questions that may be
raised but
can i please remind members that there
is one exempt appendix
appendix to the report if you need to
make reference to
exempt appendix 2 or wish to ask
questions on it can you please indicate
before speaking
as it will be necessary to move a
recommendation
to exclude the press and public first so
with that in mind are there any
questions from the executive please
and i can see uh council award but can
you just assure me that you're not going
to
drift into the exempt part of the report
uh leader yes i will not be dipping into
uh that part of the report at all um
i i would like to support you know the
work that has been done
and i would also like to draw attention
uh to the possibilities that have opened
up to us which
we need to explore is a bit too early
yet
with the chancellor's speech today
in the budget which does give uh
openings
to business that i think we need to
investigate
and see where we go with those so i
think that's very very important to
to really understand what is there and
how it will help
our high streets to develop and improve
as we come out of of this pandemic
so that's the main thing i would be
looking to encourage
going forward thank you
council award thank you very much indeed
are there any other
questions from members of the executive
or points they wish to make
if not uh i will turn to the
two recommendations set out at
paragraphs 1.1 and 1.2
and i will read them out number one
is to publicly market the leasehold
opportunity of the council-owned asset
known as the former crown hill public
convenience
it read on the plan set out in appendix
1
for commercial use and number 2
recommendation is to delegate authority
to the assistant director
assets and commercial in consultation
with the portfolio for
commercial business local economy and
leisure
to review the expressions of interest
resulting from the marketing exercise
and finalize the terms of the lease with
the successful
applicant members i i will move the two
recommendations but uh
do i have a second please i'll second
that chairman
thank you councillor
members again are you happy to vote on
the recommendations one and two together
i will assume you're in agreement unless
you click on the raised hand
icon
i can't see anyone indicating so we will
take the two together
please unmute yourself and advise me if
you're not able to use the electronic
hand and raise your
hand manually so it can be counted
members if anyone would like a recorded
vote to be taken please click on the
raised hand icon
once so i can't see
anyone indicating
so voting will be done now on an
electronic show of hands
all those in favor of the
recommendations please click on the
raised hand
icon once
chairman that's fine again i think uh
that's
unanimous and um thank you
members so
that i believe uh concludes the
business for the evening and at
um 1959
to be precise
and close thank you very much indeed for
your attendance thank you very much
indeed members
visiting members and members of the
public thank you thank you later